- [Voiceover] Let's see if we
can simplify this expression
and like always, pause the
video and have a go at it.
Now this one is interesting
because it involves two variables,
but it's really the same
ideas that we've done
when we factored things with one variable.
So, for example, up here in the numerator,
while I never liked having
a non-one coefficient
on the second degree term here,
I mean, sometimes you have to,
but it looks like every term
here is divisible by five,
so let's factor out of five first.
So the numerator, I can rewrite
as five times,
five times, you factor out of
five here, you get x squared.
Factor out of five
here, you get plus four.
Actually, I'm gonna rewrite it as four y x
and you'll see in a
second why I'm doing that.
Actually, I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why I'm
doing that right now,
why I'm writing the y there
is that this way, it seems to,
it seems to hit the pattern
of how we're used to seeing quadratics.
So let's see. So you have
x squared plus four y x,
you can view the four y's a coefficient
on the first degree in x term,
on the x term right over there,
plus four y squared
and it's gonna be over,
over.
Now, the denominator here,
can we factor this out?
Well, let's just think about it.
Do we know two numbers,
or I guess we would say,
do we know two expressions
that when you multiply,
you get negative six y squared
and then when you add them,
you get negative x y.
Sorry, when you add
them, you get negative y.
That's actually why I like
to write and get like this.
Actually, let me rewrite this.
This is the same thing as negative y x.
And so you can view the
coefficient here as negative y.
And so when you think of two
numbers or two expressions,
a times b, that is equal
to negative six y squared
and when I add them, a plus b,
that is equal to negative y.
And so you can imagine, both of them
are going to be expressions,
a and b are gonna be
expressions that involve y.
And so, let's see, if this
was just a negative one
and if this was just a
negative six, what we would do,
we would do negative
three and positive two.
Now let's see. If we did negative three y
and positive two y, that indeed
is going to be equal to
negative six y squared
and negative three y plus two y
does indeed equal negative y.
So that's our a and b right there.
And it seems a little mysterious.
How did Sal just all of a
sudden get negative two y,
or negative three y and positive two y?
Let me write an analogous quadratic here
that only has one variable.
If I were to write x
squared minus x minus six
and I were to ask you to factor that out,
you say, "Oh, okay."
I have negative two.
I have negative three times
negative two is negative six
and if I add them, well that's
going to be negative one.
So you'd say, "Well that's going to be
"x minus three times x plus two."
And so the only difference
between this and that
is instead of having just a negative one,
you have a negative one y.
Instead of having just
a negative six here,
you have a negative six y squared.
And so you could just think of this
instead of just negative
three and positive two,
negative three y and positive two y.
Hopefully that makes
sense and if it doesn't,
I encourage you to kind
of play around with this,
multiply these out a little bit,
get a little bit more familiar with this.
But now that we know that
it can factored like this,
let's rewrite this.
This is going to be x minus three y
times x plus two y.
And nothing seems to
simplify out just yet,
but it looks like what
we have in magenta here
can be simplified further.
We're gonna do a very similar exercise
to what we did just now.
What two expressions if I multiply,
I'm gonna get four y squared
and if I add them, I get four y?
It looks like two y would do the trick.
So it seems like we can
rewrite the numerator.
This is going to be.
So let me draw a little
line here to make it clear
that this is,
this is going to be equal to five
times
x plus two y times,
I could say this is x plus two y squared
or I could just say x plus
two y times x plus two y.
Once again, two y times
two y is four y squared.
Two y plus two y is four y.
And that's all going to be over,
that is all going to be over
x minus three y
times x plus two y.
And so now, I have a
common factor, x plus two y
in both the numerator and the denominator,
so I can handle x plus two
y divided by x plus two y,
well that's just going to be one
if we assume that x plus
two y does not equal zero.
And that's actually an
important constraint
because once we cancel this
out, you lose that information.
If you want this to be
algebraically equivalent,
we could say that x plus two
y cannot be equal to zero
or another way you could say it
is that x cannot be equal to,
cannot be equal to negative two y.
I just subtracted two y
from both sides there.
And so what you're left with,
and we can redistribute this five
if we wanna write it out in expanded form.
We could rewrite it as,
the numerator would be five x.
Let me write it over here.
Five x plus 10 y.
And the denominator is x minus three y.
But once again, if we want it
to be algebraically equivalent,
we would have to say x cannot be equal to,
x cannot be equal to negative two y.
And now this is algebraically equivalent
to what we had up here
and you can argue that
it's a little bit simpler.